In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion, for July 21st, on which we commemorate our righteous
Father Simeon of Homs, full for Christ's sake and his companion, John.
On the 21st of the month, we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father Simeon of
Emesa, the full for Christ, and John, his companion in Askeesys.
Saints Simeon and John were from Syria and lived during the reign of Justinian.
John, at the age of 22, had just married, and Simeon, two years older, only had his
old mother for family. Finding a bond of friendship while on a pilgrimage to the
holy places that they had undertaken for the feast of the exaltation of the cross,
they decided to continue to travel together.
When they arrived in the region of Jericho, John told his companion that the men who lived
in the monasteries near the Jordan were like angels of God, and pointing towards the road
that led there, he said, this is the road that leads to life.
Then indicating the great highway he added, and this is the road that leads to death.
After having prayed and drawn lots about the road they should take, they went to the monastery
of St. Yerassimos with great joy, forgetting all that binds to the world.
The abbot of the monastery, blessed Nikon, had been given a revelation concerning the arrival
of the two young men, and he met them at the door to welcome them, and exhort them to renunciation,
prophesying what would be their future way of life.
At their request, Nikon answered them immediately, and clothed them in the holy monastic habit, introducing
them to a new life by a second baptism.
Fearful, however, of losing the divine zeal that burned in their hearts, and the resplendent
glory that they had seen on the monastic habit, they decided two days later to leave the
monastery and go apart from all men to live in the desert abandoned to providence.
They directed their steps toward the dead sea, and arrived in a part of the desert called
Aranonas, where they found some buildings and supplies left by a hermit who had died a few
days earlier.
But as soon as they began their ascetic endeavors in solitude, they were assailed by the memory
of their dear ones, John of his wife, and Simeon of his mother.
After pressure from these thoughts and the trials of Sloth, Asidia, they were close to abandoning
their struggle.
But every time the memory of the effulgent glory that they had seen over the monastic habit
and the appearing of their spiritual father in a dream gave them courage to persevere.
They lived in cells, a stone's throw from each other, and when they were overwhelmed by temptation
or sloth, they met to pray together.
They then recounted their visions to each other and rejoiced to be delivered by God from preoccupation
with their kinsfolk in order to persevere night and day in undistracted prayer.
They thus made such progress that in a very few years they were counted worthy to be visited
by God and receive the gift of working miracles.
After spending thirty years in the desert exposed to the rigors of the climate and the innumerable
machinations of the devil, Simeon, who had attained blessed impossibility through the grace of the
Holy Spirit who dwelt in him, suggested to his companion that he himself leave the desert
in order to save others by exposing the foolishness of the world by the power of Christ.
John, believing that Simeon was the victim of demonic delusion,
admonished him and reminded him of the promise that they had both made never to be separated.
But no argument could overcome Simeon's resolution and believing that his decision came from divine
inspiration. John let him go after having made him promise that they would meet again before leaving
this life. Simeon first made a pilgrimage to Jerusalem. Once after having prayed for three days in
the holy places, he left for Emesa, having decided to feign folly to carry out his ministry of salvation.
He was thus the first to embrace this perilous askees of folly for Christ,
applying literally the words of the Apostle. If any man among you seem to be wise in this world,
let him become a fool that he may be wise. His whole purpose was to save souls either through
ridiculous behavior and calculated artifices, or by the miracles that he worked in offering himself
to derision and contempt, or by the teaching and prophetic words that he spoke while feigning folly.
In all this, he strove to remain hidden and unknown to men in order to flee their praise and honor,
living in the world as though in the desert. He made his entrance into the town, dragging,
on a rope tied to his belt, a dead dog, which he had found on a pile of manure and pursued by a
mocking gang of schoolchildren. The next day, being a Sunday, he went into the church and began to
put out the candles, throwing nuts on the flames. When they tried to chase him out, he stepped onto
the ambon and bombarded the women with nuts. Finally thrown out, he overturned the tables of the
pastry-maker who beat him up. A fritter-seller had pity on him and suggested to Simeon that he
look after his booth. But Simeon set to giving away his merchandise to passers-by and greedily eating
the fritters as he had been fasting for a week, warned by his wife the merchant belabored him and
drove him away. That evening, Simeon took a bare handful of burning charcoal and lit incense on it.
But, as soon as a merchant's wife saw him, he, pretending to be burned, put the embers in his coat,
which also took no harm. Later on, he brought about the conversion of the merchant,
who was a disciple of Severius of Antioch, by driving out a demon. Simeon then entered the
service of a tavernkeeper, who showed himself cruel and pitiless toward him, although the saint's
buffoonery gave him more trade. One day, he punished Simeon harshly for having broken a pint
jug of wine. But when he himself saw a snake had released its venom in the wine, he broke all the
rest of the crockery in trying to kill the reptile. From that time, looked on as a saint by his
patron, Simeon pretended to want to dishonor the merchant's wife, and the latter, alerted by his wife's
cries, drove him away with blows. The man of God lived right in the town, impassable, and is
though free of the cares of the flesh, and the conventions of modesty, relieving himself in the
street, going naked into the part of the public baths reserved for women. His clothes wrapped round
his head, dancing with actresses whose hands he held, or playing with prostitutes, without feeling
the slightest carnal stirring, and keeping his spirit imperturbably occupied with the work of God.
He used this strategy to make the acquaintance of loose women, and secretly promised them a large
sum of money if they would keep chaste. When he learned that one of his friends had fallen back into
luxury, he punished her either with a sickness, or by allowing a demon to torment her. He had also
received the grace of abstinence, and spent the great fast without eating anything. When great Thursday
came, though, he sat at a pastry-maker's stall and devoured cream cakes to the great scandal of the
bigoted. On other occasions, after having spent the week in fasting, he ate meat in public. One day,
he began throwing stones at some passersby who were meaning to go down a haunted road, thus preserving
them from perdition. Another time he afflicted some young girls who were jeering at him with a squint,
and then healed some of them by kissing their eyes, but left the others in that state, as he saw
that they would otherwise fall into debauchery. On Sundays, he stood at the church door
eating sausages that he had wrapped round his shoulders like a deacon's stall, holding in his left
hand a pot of mustard with which he painted the mouths of any who mocked at him. He healed a peasant
who had been struck with blindness after stealing goats from his neighbor by coating his eyes with mustard.
He once paralyzed the hand of a trickster by throwing a stone at him and then healed him by appearing
to him in a vision and making him promise to abandon his trade. Yet another time he began beating the
pillars of the school with a whip, thus predicting the earthquake that would soon destroy the city of
Antioch in the year 588. And when the quake took place, the pillars that he had whipped remained
standing. Before an epidemic of plague, he embraced all the children who were to become its victims,
wishing them a good journey. He often went into the houses of the wealthy, practicing his usual
buffoonery and pretending to embrace the women servants. One of them, having accused him of getting
her with child, Simeon took care of the woman during her pregnancy, but she was unable to give birth
until she had revealed the name of the real father. The Holy Fools solicitude extended to everyone,
especially the possessed, of whom he healed a great many by his prayer after having pretended to be like
them. A Jewish artisan saw him one day flanked by two angels. He wanted to reveal the saint's secret,
but Simeon appeared to him in a dream and set a seal on his mouth. The same thing happened to all who
discovered his virtue. They found themselves incapable of spreading it abroad. By means of all these
prophetic acts and public harangs in his simulation of folly, Saint Simeon, who always addressed and treated
men as fools, or mindless, denounced the crimes of some and the thefts and debauchery of others,
thus bringing the habit of sin to an end through almost the whole town of Emisa.
Possessing nothing in this world, he spent all his nights in prayer in a dilapidated hut,
but he left each morning after having bathed the earth with tears for the salvation of his brethren.
He then went into the town, his head crowned with an olive branch and holding a twig in his hand,
dancing and crying out, victory for the emperor and for the town. He signified by these words,
the victory acquired by the intellect and by his soul in the striving of prayer.
God had also allowed his hair and beard not to grow during all his years in Emisa,
so that he was deprived of the respect accorded to monks by their outward appearance.
He only spoke rationally with a deacon called John, whose son he had saved from a false accusation
of murder. At these times a delightful fragrance came from his mouth, but he threatened his interlocutor
with terrible torments in the future life if he devolged his secret.
When he had finished his course two days before leaving this life,
Simeon recounted his life to the deacon and revealed to him that in fulfillment of the promise
that they had made to each other, he had seen in a vision his companion John the ascetic,
with a crown on his head, bearing the words, the crown of patience in the desert.
And John had replied that he, Simeon, would wear the crown of all the souls he had saved by his
buffoonery. After having exhorted the deacon to mercy and never to approach the holy sanctuary
with evil thoughts in his heart against anyone, he took leave of him. He retired to his hut,
and not wanting to become an object of wonder by his death, he slid under a pile of wood,
but always lay there so that it would look as though he had been crushed to death.
As those who knew him well had not seen him in the town for a couple of days,
they went to his hut and found him dead.
Believing that he had been the victim of an accident, they did not even bother to wash the body,
but buried him with neither candles nor hymns in the cemetery reserved for foreigners.
When the cortege passed by the house of a Jewish glass-blower who had been converted by Simeon,
the Jew heard such salmity has had never been heard on earth, sung by a vast but invisible crowd.
Stupified, he looked through the window and saw just two men, caring the remains of the man of God.
He then cried out, blessed are you, you fool, because deprived of the accompaniment of human salmity,
you have the heavenly powers honoring you with their hymns, and he went and buried him with his own hands.
When Deacon John learned of the saint's death, he went to the cemetery and opened the grave,
but he found it empty and realized that the Lord had glorified his servant by taking him to glory in
the body before the general resurrection. It was only thus that the people of Emesa understood
that a new apostle had lived among them to bring about their salvation while remaining hidden.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord Jesus Christ our God have mercy on us and save us.